Vladimir Putin just called out the  United States of America in a recent  speech he said you cannot feed your  people with printed dollars in social  media you need food and energy but  Western Elites have no desire to find a  solution to the food and energy crisis  that they created Vladimir Putin invaded  Ukraine we shouldn't tolerate that  nonsense but at the same time we should  separate out the man from what he's  saying there's a lot of stuff we can  learn and it's true the internet is not  real life we still need food and energy  if we get pushed into a food and energy  crisis there's a lot of people who are  going to suffer globally